der umstrittene milliardär des base und
gründer von amazon sowie dem
raumfahrtunternehmens blue origin ist
nach elon musk der zweitreichste mensch
der welt base vermögen alleine wächst
dabei im schnitt um 3000 dollar pro
sekunde als die i o gewaltige
unternehmen müssen sie beide täglich
entscheidungen treffen die
milliarden-beträge und tausende von jobs
beeinflussen und sind konstant einem
enormen mentalen druck ausgesetzt wie
ihr euch vielleicht erinnert habe ich
schon mal eine woche strikt nach der
routine von allen masc gelebt und mir
genau wie er jede einzelne minute des
tages mit arbeits durchgeplant chef was
macht das aber etwas anders denn
und ab 17 uhr sagt er nur so
denke ich mir da nur so was das geht und
das soll auch noch produktiver sein weil
ich meinen der typ stellt sich nicht mal
ein wecker morgens und fängt einfach
erst um 10 an zu arbeiten ich will
herausfinden ob das funktioniert uns
dafür eine woche die tägliche routine
von jeff faces durchziehen aktuell stehe
ich direkt auf mache mich direkt an die
arbeit und hört erst auf wenn ich
schlafen gehe und obwohl auf diesem
kanal schon deutlich weniger videos
erscheinen als früher bleibt neben allen
projekten leider trotzdem viel zu wenig
zeit für die menschen die mir wichtig
sind sollte diese routine für mich also
erfolgreich sein dann wäre das wirklich
viel krasser als jeder lotto gewinnen
dieses t shirt hier ist übrigens mal in
aller erster mensch und zeigt genau wie
dieses weiße shirt hier und der schwarze
rudi ein muster bestehend aus den
blaupausen meiner projekte die ich hier
vor ort für meine videos hand gezeichnet
habe wie zb für das selbst fahrende auto
oder das windrad dass ich hier in meinen
videos gebaut habe alles hat so einen
geilen retro look und ist so ein
bisschen an die zeichnungen von leonardo
da vinci angelehnt wie zum beispiel von
diesen allerersten flugmaschinen dir
vielleicht kennt schaut also gerne mal
auf tumore punkt shop über den link in
der video beschreibung vorbei und macht
euch ein kleines weihnachtsgeschenk
jeff base ja nur weil seine routine er
entspannt sein soll heißt das nicht dass
es nicht auch klare regeln gibt die
erste lernt er jetzt kennen als erstes
werde ich jetzt zum aller ersten mal
seit jahren ohne weg ins bett gehen wir
haben jetzt gerade 10 uhr 30 sollte also
eigentlich hinhauen zwischen 36 und 8
uhr wieder aufzustehen oder alter bis
zum
28 25 bin ich jetzt aufgewacht nach
exakt acht stunden wenn ich direkt ein
geschaffen so waren sechs und damit
weiter im programm nach dem
morgendlichen gang ins bad den man wohl
selbst als milliardär nicht von anderen
erledigen lassen kann ist es zeit für
eine tätigkeit die wahrscheinlich jeder
als allererstes abgeben würde den
abwasch der in meinem fall noch vom
wochenende über geblieben ist
[Musik]
und ich dachte ich könnte mich endlich
mal davor drücken manche milliardäre wie
auch zum beispiel bill gates schwören
aber darauf banale aufgaben wie den
abwasch und die frühstück zubereitung in
ihren tagesablauf zu integrieren die
gedanken schweifen zu lassen kann
angeblich wie eine kleine meditation
wirken und hilft den kopf frei vom
stress zu bekommen
bis dahin ist an diesem morgen noch sehr
viel zeit also frühstücke ich erstmal
entspannt und lasse bei einem guten buch
die arbeit ganz einfach warten sagen
jetzt recht und rast gefühl morgens also
ein spannender zugehen erst um 10 mit
der arbeit anfangen das ist einfach kaum
ein anderes leben was jetzt die urlaub
projekt hat aber durchaus einen sinn
denn wo soll der kopf auf die nächsten
zwei stunden vorbereitet werden die für
jeff bezos die wichtigsten des tages
denn so von zehn bis zwölf macht der jf
irgendwas haiku mäßig ist es nicht dass
irgendwas was ich jemals macht haiku
werde die meisten konzentration braucht
aber wenn ich video skript da setzt
manchmal das intro für dieses video was
er gerade vorhin gesehen habt und das
machen
[Musik]
ich muss es gleich nochmal einem 3d
modell werden davor werde ich aber was
zu essen bestellen denn gleich 12 uhr
und da ist mittagspause ich habe nämlich
den notiz chef base ist gesund und
angeblich gerne bei essen steht hier
noch ein mini cooper ist gut das ist mir
jetzt nicht teil er ist sich aber auch
gerne und jetzt werde ich ein paar
finale sachen am eclipse dem modell
anschauen also das spiel zwar ganz
normal in medias während base um diese
zeit meetings abhält die die höchste
konzentration erfordern und
entscheidungen trifft welche das leben
tausender beeinflussen muss ich
natürlich noch selbst dinge umsetzen und
nicht nur entscheidungen für andere
treffen übrigens sind diese sogenannten
haiku entscheidungen von base vielleicht
meist gewinnbringend aber oft nicht die
humanste dieses jahr kam zum beispiel
daraus dass die strukturen die amazon
und base im konzern eingerichtet haben
zwar sehr effizient sind die mitarbeiter
dafür aber auch oft streng überwacht
werden und sich durch zeitdruck manchmal
sogar dazu gezwungen sehen in flaschen
zu pinkeln und das ist nur ein
kritikpunkt an amazon business
entscheidungen feierabend also nicht
ganz mittagspause essen gibt
papa denke dass jeff bridges beim
lieferanten trinker geben würde ich weiß
nicht wieso ist mit honig auto bestellt
ich habe echte vorgestellt oder da steht
drauf
ja ist so
was machen egal wie sie sich aus beim
essen ich weiß nicht reinging mit
quatschen meetings nachrichten nämlich
zu mir sagen wir mal die neue regel nach
dem essen stets dann die arbeit an die
weniger konzentration erfordert und
anschließend kommt für mich direkt eine
der wichtigsten regeln von base zum
einsatz die für mich aber vermutlich die
schwerste werden wird ungefähr mit 18
uhr 20h einmal zu lange arbeitete sitzen
wo wir eigentlich lunchtime und dann hat
er so freizeitmäßig und ich muss
gestehen dass ich ein bisschen dran
gewöhnen und ich habe auch noch keinen
bock auf oft zu hören
das mache ich jetzt den ganzen tag ich
muss meine hobbys suchen es ist schlimm
in meine hobbys also 3d 3d modellieren
projekte bau nämlich die gerätschaften
entwickeln oder irgendwie sowas lernen
ist ja eigentlich mein hobby auch wenn
ich beruflich mache wird später einfach
eine rote socken oder so dass man
trotzdem super gerne schwierig
[Musik]
jetzt also nicht
nein
[Musik]
sagen wir 30 ist das eben habe ich jetzt
bald fertig eigentlich auch so ein
bisschen eher entspannung zu haben also
der hat rechts muss mal so
und so wir gehen für mich der nächste
spannende tag im leben vom ehemaligen
amazon wieder entspannt aufstehen
meditativ frühstück machen uns dann in
aller ruhe essen
[Musik]
natürlich auch lustig das meine
mitarbeiter sind neuen anfang habe ich
hier noch bis zum 10
[Musik]
klar bei so einem riesen konzern
arbeitet die immer jemand also auch
quasi automatisch dann mein chef weiß
was nicht arbeitet egal ob erst zum 10
mitarbeit anfängt oder sonst fahren und
ich finde den ansatz dass uns so oder so
auf harmonie setzt anstatt auf 120
stunden über durch ballern auch total
neues aber normal verhält als erstes
abzuarbeiten und hört dann auch erst 56
stunden nach der anderen auf und da
jetzt zusehen dass die alle einfach
schon am arbeiten ist während ich hier
einfach mal entspannen bin ist schon
irgendwie das gefühl dabei ist
entspanntes lesen natürlich weit davon
entfernt und produktiv zu sein und macht
mich insgesamt hoffentlich sogar
leistungsfähiger diese technik hat sich
chef übrigens nicht selbst ausgedacht
sondern sie basiert tatsächlich auf
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen wir
treffen jeden tag hunderte von
entscheidungen nicht nur bei der arbeit
sondern auch im alltag was ziehe ich
heute an was frühstücke ich welchen
apfel kaufe ich im supermarkt und die
mehr entscheidungen wir treffen umso
niedriger wird deren qualität in der
psychologie nennt sich dieses konzept
die süßen fertig also zu deutsch
entscheidungsmöglichkeit dass wir zum
beispiel auch von süßigkeiten herstellen
ausgenutzt wenn wir am ende unseres
einkauf ist nach dutzenden
kaufentscheidungen an der kasse stehen
uns eine leckere süßigkeit an lacht und
wir uns dann für den kurzen zucker kick
entscheiden anstatt für den gesunden
apfel den wir vorhin schon gekauft haben
uns genau diese schlechten
entscheidungen möchte welches vermeiden
das funktioniert haben wir gut wenn man
chef eines riesen konzerns ist und der
job wirklich in anführungsstrichen nur
aus großen entscheidungen bestätigt habe
dabei in meiner arbeit allerdings
trotzdem noch so einige probleme
ich hatte pünktlich eigentlich um knapp
nach 17 uhr feierabend gemacht ich
musste dann aber noch was wichtiges
machen es ist echt super schwierig
einfach alles wichtige zwischen 10 und
12 uhr erledigt zu haben kann die
unwichtigen sachen zwischen 13 und 17
uhr wollen dass man danach auch noch was
macht ich konkret muss jetzt noch eine
idee aus reifen für den potenziellen
sponsor des kanals aber eigentlich chef
bei solch wichtigen dinge ja auf den
nächsten tag 10 uhr aber ich denke auch
das etwas ist was man auch lernen kann
ist es ja auch erst heute tag 2 der
dienstag morgen will ich aber das alles
am schnürchen läuft
punkt 13 uhr geht es direkt weiter nach
einer einstündigen pause ist eigentlich
schon cool also genau getaktet zu haben
das man halt ein planer okay dann mach
mal pause und nicht einfach über deshalb
passt es ist auch an schließlich
supercool erst um 10 uhr mit der arbeit
anzufangen und davor als zwei stunden
umkehren zu können halt zum lesen zu
essen und sich mehr zeit lassen können
aber dadurch dass man erst um 10 anfängt
ist jetzt halt schon 13 und jetzt ist
auch schon bei 69 gefühlt acht neun ganz
sacht nix da sind sechs stunden
konzentrierter arbeit so also dass es so
schnell vorbei sind wir das kraft wenn
ich jetzt aber unterm strich trotzdem
gleich viel oder sogar noch mehr
gebacken bekäme als normal obwohl es
sich kaum nacharbeit anfühlt und ich
jeden abend so viel zeit habe um zum
beispiel wie hier mit zwei ps fünf zu
spielen dann wäre das wirklich was
großes ich merke richtig dass es halt
auch mega man es geht also
erstmal anfangen schon umsetzen aufhören
aber ich kriege dann potenziell und
nicht alles gebacken ich experimentiere
gerade einen neuen und stabileren kugler
dann für den mac repair möglichst bald
aus kommen sollten und die vielen wenn
und aber hilft musste halt stress des
monat wissens klickt sich alles nicht in
zwei drei wochen
immer wieder habe ich über die tage
hinweg base interviews angesehen und
angehört es ist schon komisch ich
stundenlang aufnahmen anzuhören von
jemanden dem man eigentlich gar nicht
cool findet und dann nebenbei noch
seinen lebensstil nachzuempfinden das
obwohl ich jetzt kein richtiger
chessbase hater bin wie viele andere
trotzdem kann man von ihm natürlich viel
lernen für mich ist das zum beispiel
folgendes er beschäftigt sich in seinen
unternehmen zb immer bereits mit seinem
plänen der zukunft und nicht mit dem
täglichen geschäft durch
vorausschauendes handeln erst so richtig
möglich wird das ist eine weitsicht die
mir total fehlt da ich den hauptteil
meiner zeit relativ gestresst den day
die tudors hinterherrennen das fazit ist
da sich technisch tief in zukunft die
sachen bisschen anders angehen werde ich
mal in sein leben darauf auszurichten
dass man nur noch ein paar
entscheidungen aber dafür gute treffen
muss macht sicherlich sinn wenn man an
der spitze von dem gigantischen
unternehmen steht aber ich hatte in der
woche bestimmt mehr geschafft wenn ich
auch mehr zeit gearbeitet hätte besser
sagt ja aber selbst das erinnerte in der
amazon start up war immer gearbeitet hat
ich denke trotzdem nicht dass ich jetzt
schon so weit bin nur noch irgendwie
sechs stunden am tag zu arbeiten mein
ziel ist aber auf jeden fall weiterhin
acht stunden zu schlafen das hat gut
geklappt und das richtig krass wäre nur
noch von 9 uhr morgens bis neun uhr
abends zu arbeiten und dann wenn er noch
was ansteht allein war damit aufzuhören
so wie jetzt mit diesem video in diesem
sinne frohe weihnachten hat eine
wunderschöne zeit mit eurer familie max
goldt den link zu meinem allerersten
merge gibt es jetzt in der video
beschreibung
[Musik]